like okay okay are you allowed to say
now that you've been streaming on
youtube for a while do you think it has
an opportunity to compete with blip in
the future
with blip i'm sorry
uh with twitch is it like a live
streamer yeah yeah yeah i think for the
next five years twitch will probably
remain the top dog but i do think twitch
is mismanaged so badly at the top like
the only way to grow on twitch and
everyone internally knows is to go on
another website and then go to twitch
yeah right yeah and i think there's a
lot of pressure for them to be
profitable and they've done like or
announced that they might like slash pay
like 30 for creators uh or they might
make people like run ads and so they've
done a lot of things that are
unfavorable but it's because amazon's
like hey you've been losing hundreds of
millions for five years now could you
please stop and eventually i think what
will break the camel's back is if they
get rid of twitch prime right well
because like another thing that i've
realized recently about twitch is that
it's i i feel like twitch like in my
mind was way more of a mature platform
uh than i thought it was because i think
what made me realize this recently was
the recent meta of just you know
streaming copyrighted shows right and
there was just nothing that was done
about that you look at something like
youtube i mean you lasted like what 24
hours or something before you had your
first yeah on youtube or something like
that dude i got knocked off so many
times for like listening to songs like
even if i listen to like the naruto like
so
yeah yeah yeah and i'm playing like a
blitz game of chess and i'm like let's
go boys
it'll just be like like oop and then
it'll take me down um
and so
it's it's crazy what you can get away
with on twitch yeah and i think a lot of
streamers would struggle even with like
the daily like hey let's react to videos
thing yeah yeah and they would just get
burned yeah i'm not really a fan of that
anyway i don't really like reacting to
videos i just i don't know why it's
tight
why why would i want to what i don't
know just watch youtube offline why are
you getting i don't know well i i agree
with you
i think
like 95 of the time the thing that i
like doing is like watching
what i do these days i i have my mods i
pay them all and i'm like hey get me a
list of like the coolest food from every
country it'll be like a like a minute
clip of all that and i'll watch them all
on stream and so it's like a compilation
of all of those with the overarching
idea of like which place is the coolest
food yeah i think you did one with like
youtubers from different countries yeah
yeah exactly and so that i do that a lot
uh but i do i get uncomfortable when i'm
just sitting there even watching like a
kurz gazette video yeah they've given me
permission to watch it but sometimes i'm
sitting there and it's almost like i
feel like i'm high and i'm like i
haven't said anything in a while
or do they know that i haven't said
anything
and then i'll watch xqc like react to
like
watch him he reacts to movie recaps yeah
i've seen him oh
you've seen this
it's a text-to-speech voice that is like
someone wrote and it'll be like a movie
like the martian it'll be like matt
damon goes to space and he has to live
there for 60 days and it's the entire
movie for 10 minutes and he just watches
it and he won't say a word
and i'm like man he's the goat
that is like a new level of just like
gaming the system yeah like what's next
just like reading like entire hollywood
scripts like text to speeches
that'd be fire just the b movie
text-to-speech yeah
sitting there reacting laughing
as if you could actually see it in your
mind
like oh rayleigh yeah
so like is it like because i've talked
to a lot of twitch streamers they
constantly talk about like the meta of
like whatever's going on in twitch how
is that set is there just like a few
people at the top just like
figuring out something new and then
everyone just kind of copies that it's
just like toilet paper you know where
like when uh when everyone was buying
toilet paper everyone's just freaking
out oh what they
everyone just like this is the meta and
you're like why why because because one
person did it yeah yeah you're right
it's just it feels like a fire set where
everything's it's the same thing on
youtube though you get it is it really i
don't know youtube
i
a lot of trends that are like a lot
easier to do i guess and you know
obviously like if mr beast starts doing
something then not everyone's going to
jump onto that because there's a high
bar of entry but if it's something like
you know like you know any of the
[ __ ] stupid youtube challenges right
it was also the same thing i guess but
like i feel like on youtube at least
there is like tangible numbers you can
be like this is the result like if you
take a hot knife and cut something
you'll get 10 million views that's
guaranteed but sometimes on twitch i
feel like she's like oh this big guy did
it and there's no like numbers saying
this improved or made it any better it's
just like just jump on it i think it's
usually related to something timely so
like our forward slash place is a great
example that could have only happened in
that window yeah i'd say that's valid
among us when it came out is because it
was hot yeah and like usually the metas
are things that are happening because
like either there's an innovation like
oh i can stream in a hot tub in a bikini
innovation
that's american continuity going forward
the car the plane amaranth in that order
uh
and so that's like usually what dictates
it but you're right like sometimes
there's lulls and like down times yeah
and then like xqc will play like fall
guys and it's like fall guys back now
and it's like yeah yeah and you can kind
of force the meta yeah i just feel like
that like one time there was a thing
where it was like the meta was putting
the v2 attack yeah for like no reason
yeah that's really but that's like a
full meter it's like yeah it's useless
right yeah it's not like chess which was
like a real like you know
it's just like falling off
i mean it's kind of coming back as
candidates i'm trying to make it a
metadata again a meta again i'm trying
to bring it back
yeah you're one of the meta setters
right yeah yeah i have the power i think
i can because i have this idea of chess
but you see the eval bar while you play
right and you've all done chess right
yeah oh was in the players see the evil
yes while you are playing you see the
eval bar which if you don't know it just
there's like a bar and it's usually
split 50 white 50 black when you start
and the better you play like the more in
one favor it is yeah and you know when
you're playing in a tournament you're
like am i doing bad am i winning like
what the [ __ ] is going on
but if you could see a bar that's like
you are doing great you'd be like cool
and you i think you play better because
of it
i don't think i would though i don't
know like
this is literally the equivalent of
having a friend behind you
yeah yeah yeah yeah yes
magnus carlson
literally just yeah
like i remember like i remember when i
when i first tried streaming chess i
thought okay i'm pretty i'm okay at
chess right yeah and then i was
trying to stream for the first time with
while reading twitch chat and like my
performance just dipped by about 20 i
swear to god because if there's a game
that's like backseat gaming puts you off
of it's chess yeah yeah because like you
constantly doubt yourself with every
every single move so
i don't know if that would help or
enhance i guess not because twitch
shit's all dumb asses the evil bar is
god
you know you eval is a literal algorithm
yeah that like works in your favor right
well okay i feel like it would it would
snowball it way more right because if
you're a head you'd get like way more
confident but if you're like even like
five percent behind i feel like that
ripped i feel like okay remake guys
i'm tilted i'm already tilted you know
i think it'd be interesting like like
for example if it says like mate in 13.
it's like okay now i spend more time
looking to find something if you don't
find it and i think it'd make you play
better and then you run the clock and
you lose yeah yeah maybe either way
i'll bring the meta back i will implore
you all to jump back into the chess meta
you've already tried you all enjoyed it
i'll
[Laughter]
i got a dm from iron mouse before this
and she's like be mean to connor and i
was like all right what the [ __ ] all
right
it's not hard yeah everyone's mean to me
just a good punching bag
i like to play more like because like
one thing that's awesome about you know
chess.com is that the ui is just so
clean but i remember like playing connor
with like a real board
and that was just like way more
challenging than like
yeah it's so hard to see things i know
yeah because you're standing up and
looking yeah
yeah
i don't understand like i think uh it's
a thing when they teach young people
they never have them play online yeah
because it's so much harder to go from
online to on the board yeah yeah as
opposed to the other way around yeah
yeah yeah it's like it's weird how much
just playing on that ui just improves
your performance and trying
trying to play with a real life chess
board is kind of like going from an
automatic car to a manual car you're
like how the [ __ ] does this work i've
completely forgotten everything yeah
church yeah that's why you beat me last
time we played in real life i i think i
had more experience playing over the
board
that's true from like childhood yeah
yeah yeah really a lot of the time it
was very good welsh chess school yeah i
guess so yeah
yeah my experience is just my uncle
beating my ass repeatedly and then
ignoring me for the rest of the day
my dad always wanted to play chess until
i started beating him and then he was
like i don't want to play anymore at
what age were you beating your dad like
ten what yeah was your dad dumb as
bricks
as a kid you have no sense of what is a
good chess player sure first time yeah i
don't know